my name is Nana otay otay I work with
the foundation for women's health
research and development called forward
I live in London and I originally come
from Ghana personally I committed to
this fight because it had worked in
northern Ghana in an area where FGM is
practice and I told myself it could have
been me I could have been born there and
I would have been helpless so I
personally took it as an African woman
to be much more involved in this work
and having worked in this area for the
last 10 years I feel that I am more and
more committed now to help bring this
issue to one end female genital
mutilation is a problem in Europe today
because it's a human rights violation
and it's one of the most intimate of
human rights violation and very often
women and girls who are affected do not
have the necessary support and services
that they require in order to enable
them to live healthy and adequate life
engaging communities who have been
affected in different ways by female
genital mutilation is very central and I
do recognize that there are challenges
in working with communities however
working with communities requires
targeting communities affected enabling
them to have the skills to have the
information and to have the confidence
to be able to break the taboo and
silence around female genital mutilation
you